نحن على عتبة
احتياطيات غير محدودة تقريبًا من الطاقة بما في ذلك
من الوقود التقليدي الغاز الطبيعي المسال والفحم النظيف
الجيل القادم من تقنيات الطاقة النووية وهيدرات الغاز
لأن
أهداف انبعاثات صافي الصفر البعيدة لن تعني
شيئًا على الإطلاق إذا
واصلنا تجاهل ميزانيات ثاني أكسيد الكربون المطبقة
اليوم  ليست
تواريخ مستقبلية بعيدة إذا استمرت الانبعاثات العالية
كما هو الحال الآن حتى لبضع سنوات
سيتم استخدام الميزانيات المتبقية بالكامل قريبًا ،
فنحن ملتزمون
بالحفاظ على عظمة خلق الله
والجمال الطبيعي
لعالمنا اليوم.
ستنضم الولايات المتحدة إلى مبادرة 1 تريليون شجرة
التي يتم إطلاقها هنا في
المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي ، إن 1 تريليون شجرة
غرس الأشجار أمر جيد بالطبع ،
لكنه ليس قريبًا بدرجة كافية مما هو
مطلوب ولا يمكن أن يحل محل
التخفيف الحقيقي وإعادة بناء الطبيعة ولكن
عجائب القرن الماضي  سيصبح شاحبًا
مقارنة بما
سيحققه المبتكرون الشباب اليوم لأنهم يفعلون ذلك
الأشياء التي لم يظن أحد أنها
مجدية للبدء ، نستمر في تبني
التكنولوجيا حتى لا نتجنبها نحن لا نطلب
منك الاعتماد على التقنيات التي
لا توجد حتى اليوم على نطاق واسع والتي
يقول العلم أنها ربما لن تفعل ذلك أبدًا